we're getting the low-hanging fruit I
mean we're getting the ones that can be
caught I mean they you know I'm sure
we'll talk about it but the anonymous
case there was a guy named AV unit he's
still I lose sleep over him because I we
didn't catch him we caught everybody
else we didn't catch him
he's good though
he pops up too once in a while on the
internet and it pisses me off yeah
what's his name again AV unit that's all
I know is his AV unit AV unit yeah I got
a funny story about about him and what
who people think he is can I actually
can we go on that brief tangent sure I
love tangents
well let me ask you uh
since he's probably he or she do we know
it's a he we have no idea okay I mean
that's another funny story about hackers
the he she issue what's the funny story
there well one of the guys in lulsec was
that was a she was a 17 year old girl
yeah uh and uh my source in the case the
the guy Sabu that I arrested and part of
it and you know we sat side by side for
nine months and then took down you know
the case and all that he was convinced
she was a girl and we said you know and
he was in love with her almost at one
point it turns out to be a 35 year old
guy living in England oh so he was
convinced there's a uh yes he was
absolutely based on what exactly by
linguistic like human-based linguistic
analysis or what she she he uh whatever
you know Kayla is what it was ended up
being like a modification of his
sister's name the real guy's sister's
name was so good at building the
backstory all these guys and it's funny
like these guys are part of a hacking
crew they social engineer the [ __ ] out
of each other yeah just to build if one
of them ever gets caught they'll
convince the everybody else that you
know they're a Brazilian uh you know ISP
owner or something like that and that's
how I'm so powerful well yeah that
social engineering aspect is part of
living a life of cyber crime or cyber
security and the offensive or defensive
so AV unit
casca also just a attention of attention
first that's my favorite tangent okay
um is it possible for me to have a
podcast conversation
was somebody who hasn't been caught yet
and because they have the conversation
they still won't be caught
and is that a good idea meaning is there
a safe way for a criminal to talk to me
at a podcast
I would think so
I would think they that someone could I
mean someone who has been living a
double life for for long enough where
you think they're not a criminal
um no no no they would have to admit
that they would say I am AV unit oh you
would want to have a conversation with
AV unit yes
um is there a way I'm just speaking from
an FBI perspective technically speaking
because I I so let me explain my
motivation or I think
I would like to be able to talk to
people from all walks of life and
understanding criminals
understanding their mind I think is very
important
and I think there's fundamentally
something different between a criminal
who's still active versus one that's
been caught the mind just from observing
it changes
completely once you're caught you you
have a big shift in your understanding
of the world
um I mean that I do have a question
about the ethics of having such
conversations but first technically uh
is is that is it possible
if I was technically advising you I
would say first off don't advertise it
don't the fewer people that you're gonna
tell that you're having this
conversation with the better
um and yeah you could if you do it in
person are you doing it in person would
be amazing yeah but they their face
would not be shown face would not be
yeah I mean you couldn't publish the
show for a while they'd have to put a
lot of trust in you that you are not
going to you're going to have to alter
those tapes uh I say tapes because it's
old school you know exactly I'm sure a
lot of people just said that like oh
[ __ ] this old guy just said tape I heard
of VHS was in the 1800s I think
um but yeah yeah you could do it they'd
have to have complete faith and trust in
you that you destroy the originals after
you've altered it what about if they
don't have faith is there a way for them
to attain security
um so uh like for me to go through some
kind of process where I meet them
somewhere where I mean you're not going
to do it without a bag over your head I
don't know if that's the life you want
to live I'm fine with a bag over my head
that's gonna take get taken out of
context well I just I think it's a
worthy effort it's a word it's worthy to
go through the hardship of that to
understand the mind of somebody I think
fundamentally conversations are a
different thing than the operation of
law enforcement understanding the mind
of a criminal I think is really
important I don't know if you're going
to have the honest conversation that
you're looking for I mean it may sound
honest but it may not be the truth I
found most times when I was talking to
criminals it's lies mixed with half
truce uh and you you kind of it's if
they're good they can keep that story
going for long enough uh if they're not
you know you kind of see the relief in
them when you finally break that wall
down
that's the job of an interviewer if the
interviewer is good then perhaps not
directly but through the gaps seeps out
the truth of the human being so not
necessarily the details of how they do
the operations and so on but just who
they are as a human being what their
motivations are what their ethics are
how they see the world what is good what
is evil do they see themselves as good
what do they see their motivation as do
they have resentment what do they think
about love for the people within their
small community do they have for example
for the government or for other nations
or for other people to the childhood
issues that led to to a different view
of the world than others perhaps have do
they have certain fetishes like sexual
and otherwise that led to their
construction of the world they might be
able to reveal some deep flaws to the
cyber security
infrastructure of our world not in
detail but like philosophically speaking
they might have
I I know you might say it's just the
narrative but they might have a kind of
ethical concern for the well-being of
the world that they're essentially
attacking the weakness of the cyber
security infrastructure because they
believe ultimately that would lead to a
safer world
so the attacks will reveal the
weaknesses
and if they're stealing a bunch of money
that's okay because that's going to
enforce you to invest a lot more money
in defending
um yeah defending things that actually
matter you know nuclear warheads and all
those kinds of things I mean I could I
could see if you know it's fascinating
to explore the mind of a human being
like that because
um I think it will help people
understand now of course
uh
it's still a person that's creating a
lot of suffering in the world which is a
problem so do you think ethically it's a
good thing to do
I don't I mean I I feel like I have a
fairly High
ethical bar that I have to put myself on
and I don't think I have a problem with
it I would love to listen to it okay
great I mean not that I'm your ethical
culture here yeah but uh well that's
interesting I mean so because I thought
you would have become jaded and
exhausted by the criminal
um mind
it's funny
um you know I I'm I'm you know fast
forwarding our story I'm very good
friends with with Hector monster or the
Cebu the guy I arrested
um and he tells stories of what he did
in his past and I'm like um that actor
you know
you know but then I listened to your
episode with Brett Johnson and I was
like ah this guy's stealing money from
from the US government and Welfare fraud
and all that sort of things it just
pissed me off and I don't know why I
have that differentiation in my head I
don't know why I think one's just oh
Hector will be Hector and then this guy
just pissed me off well you didn't feel
that way about Hector until you probably
met him well I didn't know Hector I knew
Sabu so I hunted down Sabu and I learned
about Hector over those nine months
we'll we'll talk about this let's finish
with yeah let's return tangent to back
to attention oh
one tangent up who's AV unit I don't
know interesting so he's at the core of
anonymous he's one of the critical
people and honestly what is known about
him there's what's known in public and
what was known because uh like side with
Hector and um he was sort of like the
the set things up guy
um so if
littlesec had like their hackers which
was Sabu and Kayla and they had their uh
their their media guy it's guy topiary
uh he lived up in the northern end of
England and uh they had a few other guys
but but AV unit was the guy that set up
infrastructure so if you need a VPN in
Brazil or something like that to pop
through
um
one of the first things Hector told me
after we arrested him is that heavy unit
was a secret service agent
and I was like oh [ __ ]
um just because he kind of lived that
lifestyle he'd be around for a bunch of
days and then all of a sudden gone for
three weeks
um and I tried to get more out of Hector
but that early on in that relationship
um you know I'm sure he was a little bit
guarded uh and maybe trying to social
engineer Me Maybe he wanted that uh that
oh [ __ ] this law enforcement involved in
this
um and and not to say I mean I I was you
know over my head with that case just
the amount of work that was going on
um so to track them all down
um plus the 350 hacks that we came in
about just military institutions
um you know it was swimming in the deep
end
um so it was just at the end of the case
I looked back and I was like oh [ __ ]
heavy unit I could have had them all uh
you know maybe that's the perfectionist
in me oh man well reach out somehow I
can't I won't say how right we'll have
to figure would you have them on yeah oh
my God if you just let me know just just
talk this [ __ ] about you the whole time
that's perfect he probably doesn't even
care about me but well now he will oh
yeah because there's a certain pleasure
of a guy who's extremely good at his job
not catching another guy who's extremely
good at his job obviously better he got
away better there you go he's still
eating at you I love it you or she if I
could meet that guy one day that he or
she that'd be great I mean I have no
power